startling spike in cyclist as the latest
report from Nevada State Police showing
the number of lives lost as more than
double what it was this time last year
now the trend has many people across our
community very concerned they're pushing
for change Sasha loft is joining us now
live at Maryland Parkway and Flamingo
were two bicyclists died in a suspected
DUI crash on Friday Sasha
it's a spot where one of those cyclists
died on Friday you can see the spots the
marks here still on the sidewalk now the
second victim involved in this crash
died today this rocking many in the area
as advocates push for change
much a lot of Las Vegas is not cyclist
friendly yet ganier komakova is one of
many concerned after a major crash
happened right in front of her apartment
this was the scene here at Maryland
Parkway and Flamingo last week after
police say Marco Benitez hit 10 cars and
killed two cyclists while driving under
the influence and it sparked another
conversation regarding safety on our
roads
the latest report from Nevada state
police shows 11 bicyclists have died in
Clark County so far this year that's
more than double what we saw this time
in 2021. it's beyond frustrating because
we work every day and Rob Hutchinson of
Southern Nevada Bicycle Coalition says
driver awareness is key but he also
believes things like wider buffered bike
Lanes could save lives and it's those
kind of things that uh will slow people
down and if you still have an accident
the chances for fatality will be your
last number comikova wants those who
cycle to keep their safety top of Mind
there are poor people you know who don't
have money
to buy a car so they just use a bike for
everyone while she encourages drivers to
always watch for others on the road
is facing multiple charges including two
counts of DUI resulting in death and
several counts of Leaning leaving the
scene of an accident involving death now
he is also due back in court tomorrow
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now